this is basically one chapter in my new
book picnic , lightning which is the
aforementioned in search of a new
reality and just to describe the book
very briefly I was very when I started
writing the book it was right before the
brexit vote it was a few months before
Trump's election and even then I noticed
that these were strange times for
reality because a lot of our sort of
more technological progress was focusing
on ideas of virtual reality and
augmented reality and that seemed to be
a new frontier you know being able to
sit in your kitchen and put a headset on
and suddenly there's a coral reef there
while you're in the kitchen as well an
augmented reality you can go around a
museum hold your phone up and be given
all these sort of extra bits of data
sort of augmenting your real experience
but it seemed to me that we hadn't
really got our hands full on the ropes
when it came to the nuts and bolts about
everyday realities the just the physical
surroundings there what it's like to be
in a room with solid tables solid chairs
it seemed a bit sort of previous or
rather precocious to suddenly you start
going on and saying we have this solid
base that we call reality and then we're
going to make it virtual and make it
augmented and really one of the main
ways that I thought our reality was
being sort of challenged or compromised
in these times as many reasons but one
of the ways I felt that our public
private reality our private realities
and our public realities were becoming
dangerously merged together and that we
were no longer had a clear division
between the private reality perhaps of
the home of our bodies of our private
thoughts and how we manifest in the
public sphere so there's just a few
things I talked about in the book before
we get to the idea of obscenity which
sort of are on this theme of the
collapse of the public and private
reality and one of them is the Internet
of Things and my editor was saying oh
don't write about the incentive things
everyone knows about it already and I
could never tell it whether the Internet
of Things is one of those things that
everyone knows about or that no one
knows about and there was a lot of sort
of scandal about a fridge fridges aren't
normally scandalous things but Samsung
developed in
a smart fridge if it has smart on it it
usually means it's connected to the
internet of things it's the ecosystem of
appliances in your house in your house
perhaps that can be sort of controlled
remotely and communicate with other
devices and there was a Samsung fridge
which leaked and it didn't leak water
which my fridge often does but it leaked
people's Gmail passwords so is a it was
sort of a soft target in the home
security system so that you could your
sort of private details could be hacked
through this fridge so no one liked that
but the Internet of Things is
interesting for me because you know that
feeling at the end of the day when you
realize that you're out of public life
for the day you're closing down the
house you're turning the lights off room
by room and there's a sense of sort of
fortification that this is me in my
private sphere I'm no longer in public
and to me the very idea of the Internet
of Things compromises this idea by the
sense that household belongings are off
out somewhere else up in the cloud
communicating sending data receiving
data did the really sort of solid walls
of the home which really have been sort
of a psychological and emotional
buttress for humans for a long time of
being sort of rewired and the home is
much more porous than it used to be this
is a campaign from earlier this July
with Tommy Hilfiger and Tommy Hilfiger
has launched a new brand of smart
wearable clothings it's called their
connect series or their go explore with
the connect Tommy Hilfiger range and
basically it's clothes with Bluetooth in
it so if you're wearing a Tommy Hilfiger
Bluetooth that piece of clothing when
you walk by shops you get rewards on
your phone you become a little brand
ambassador for them they're able to
track where you are at all times they
know what you're buying you know if
you're buying from them or not etc so
there's this idea that they're sort of
the one of the most private
relationships we have is the cloth on
our bodies and the fact that even that
is being sort of LinkedIn and there was
a designer of a tech designer in 2014
who predicted that the future of
wearables would go way beyond just the
Fitbit and how many steps and your
heartrate and stuff and move into
clothing itself
and he said well be really exciting for
him as a third party sort of advertiser
would be b8 to be able to tell how we
were feeling how our heart rate was
doing how various biometrics were
reading in our body it's like we were
strapped up to an ICU device at all
times through our clothing and then
through though that biometric data he'd
be able to what he said give me relic
relevant offers through my phone
depending on how the clothes were
telling him that I was feeling at any
one moment but it all speaks to this way
in which the private self in the public
self is becoming rendered much more of a
hybrid this is the influencer now I love
the name the influencer it reminds me of
a Batman villain the influencer is in
town mm-hmm
and what's so great about the name of
the influencer it doesn't even so
describe what it's trying to do you know
built into the very name is the idea
that I will be manipulating you
so influences for those who don't know
is sort of a generic term for someone
who's amassed such a large online
following so on Instagram they may have
80,000 followers on Instagram and as
such advertisers will pay them to
advertise their products now this isn't
especially new we've had spokespeople
for many years but it's it's unusual
that so many so-called ordinary citizens
are becoming poster people for brands so
this is an example of an influencer and
how it works is within sort of the
everyday life of the influencer they may
have regular photographs of themselves
but then one will be a sponsored post in
which they're wearing a paid these
sunglasses for instance maybe and she
may have been paid to wear them but
unless you click on the image and see
some of the captions you won't
necessarily know what is the sponsored
item you know by law you have to say
this is an ad or a sponsored partnership
with someone in the fine print somewhere
but if you're just scrolling through
these pages it's very hard to sort of
tell what is sort of someone's personal
choice and what is a commercial
relationship and I had a bit of a dream
that I never have prophetic dreams while
I was writing this book but I had one in
which I was thinking about influences
and I had a dream about a little boy in
the near future and also the little boy
was me so was one of those dreams but
this little boy was at a restaurant and
looking through the menu and he couldn't
decide what to have and he
he said to his parents you know what I
just can't remember what I actually like
and what I'm paid to like and I thought
that was sort of a very dystopia concept
vision of the future so everyone wants
to turn that into a movie you're welcome
to do so I'm not gonna pursue that any
further you may recognize this woman
this is Kim Kardashian she is sort of a
poster person sort of on a huge scale of
the person whose commodified their
private lives and in 2016 there was a
notorious selfie of Kim Kardashian in
which she posed herself naked in her
bathroom and she put black bars over her
private parts herself which was a funny
display of sort of self-censorship
and self-revelation all at once and now
while that was sort of that got lots of
attention what interested me more was
the way in which the backstage view that
Kim Kardashian has made her sort of
bread and butter as it were was fully on
display so people might be looking at
this selfie of her and thinking oh but
that those the actual pot lights that
Kim Kardashian has that's the beige
towel in her cream bathroom and this is
sort of a an insatiable interest that we
seem to be cultivating in the behind the
scenes view all the time and that's the
main argument that I want to propose to
you is that the backstage view or the
behind-the-scenes view has become the
central view in our digital cultural
life and what are some of the
ramifications for that so here we come
to the word obscene and the idea of
obscenity people when they say you know
digital life is the big problem Digital
life is its obscenity you might think
that we're talking about internet
pornography and the proliferation of
pornographic images and the huge problem
that is causing for young people
especially being doused all the time
saturated in internet pornography and
that's a very real concern and should be
talked about but I my proposition is
that there's another form of obscenity
which is arguably more pervasive and
structural and sort of now built into
the very form of our lives and what's
good for me to make this argument is
that
the word obscene etymologically has a
sort of a forked root etymologists
aren't quite sure where we get obscene
from there's the Latin root obscene am
and seen him here refers to sort of
filth or mark sometimes buttocks or
genitals so that sort of the moral
moralizing view which would be like be
obscene to pornography something so
called filthy or dirty or whatever but
there's also a lot of credible evidence
to suggest that obscene comes from the
greek and it comes from obscene air and
my Greek isn't that great but when I was
reading the audiobook the producers
showed me it was called skin hair if
anyone wants to correct me you're
welcome to I just generally call it
obscene and that literally means the off
stage or the off scene perspective and
that's what many people think the reefs
or obscenity comes from so what was this
little skiing Oscar Nair well this takes
us back to the 5th century BC in the
theatre of dionysus
you